kim kardashian is slamming kanye west on
social media and she isn't holding back
yep it all started on friday when kanye
posted a screenshot of their eldest
daughter north on tick tock he asks in
the caption quote since this is my first
divorce i need to know what i should do
about my daughter being put on tick tock
against my will
it's an issue he's raised before like in
this interview last month don't have my
daughter
wearing lipstick on tick-tock i don't
have on tick-tock at all
if i'm gonna approve that almost
immediately kim claps back with this
lengthy response
quote kanye's constant attacks on me in
interviews and on social media is
actually more hurtful than any tick tock
north might create as the parent who is
the main provider and caregiver for our
children i am doing the best to protect
our daughter while also allowing her to
express creativity in a medium that she
wishes with adult supervision of course
kim is referring to the joint tiktok
account she shares with north the duo
often posts videos like this
[Music]
kim continues by writing that the former
couple's divorce has been difficult for
their four kids quote kanye's obsession
with trying to control and manipulate
our situation so negatively and publicly
is only causing further pain for all
putting it simply the beauty mogul says
that kanye is making it quote impossible
to have a co-parenting relationship
that is sad to me and that's not what i
want the rapper wasted no time clapping
back posting kim's statement to his
instagram and making multiple
accusations in the caption quote what do
you mean by main provider america saw
you try to kidnap my daughter on her
birthday by not providing the address
you put security on me inside of the
house to play with my son then accused
me of stealing i had to take a drug test
after chicago's party cause you accused
me of being on drugs tracy romulus
stopped manipulating kim to be this way
e.t has reached out to kim and tracy who
handles kim's pr for comment
now a source is opening up to e.t about
the drama explaining that quote kim has
been very hurt and upset by kanye's
antics involving her recently she's been
trying to take the high road but our
source says kim felt she had no choice
but to publicly respond we have
different views sometimes we have
different poor things this isn't the
first time kanye has aired their dirty
laundry on social media
like when he referenced in his instagram
clapback the rapper claimed he wasn't
invited to his daughter chicago's fourth
birthday party last month there's also
this
god sent me from that crash
just so i could beat pete davis's ass
yeah that's yay's song easy with the
game rapping about kim's new beau pete
davidson now are you gonna kiss me or
not
i sure am jasmine
not only has kim moved on but kanye has
two with his new flame julia fox and
word is to make kim jealous
a source recently told et quote while
kanye has definitely been having fun
with julia fox he has also been doing a
lot of things with julia to get any sort
of rise or reaction from kim
[Music]
you